[Music]
new evidence is helping police in the
nearly 12 year-old murder case of a
beloved beauty queen Tara Grinstead
disappeared from a small Georgia City
back in 2005 police now have a suspect
in the death of the high school history
teacher 48 hours correspondent that's
Peter Van Zandt began investigating this
case back in 2008 and he has the only
interview with a woman whose tip led
police to that suspect Peter good
morning good morning it became the
largest missing-persons case in Georgia
history for more than 11 years this
murder mystery remained unsolved until
this February when two new suspects were
identified I'm an 11th grade history
teacher
Irwin County High School and I just
completed my first year teaching and I
loved every bit of it
Tara Grinstead disappearance from her
home in Ocilla Georgia in 2005 made no
sense to her friends family and police I
knew something was wrong I knew that it
was serious I knew that something beyond
her control had happened in what became
the largest missing-persons case in
Georgia history investigators
interviewed more than 100 people friends
ex-boyfriends anyone who had any
relationship with Tara in nearly 27
years with the Georgia Bureau of
Investigation I've never encountered
such a complex and difficult case but a
shocking twist came in February you have
information you believe that can help
solve that case when this woman Brooke
Sheridan came forward to the Georgia
Bureau of Investigation with information
from the man she loves her boyfriend
beau Dukes I felt like I was gonna be
sick I didn't know who I was staring at
I didn't know who he was beau confided
to Brooke that his friend Ryan Duke had
told him that he had killed Tara
Grinstead back in 2005
Ryan convinced beau to help him dispose
of her body
both men were former students in Tara's
history class why would Ryan Duke have
murdered Tara Grinstead
he said that's something that only God
and Ryan know Brook faced a moral
dilemma turning in the man she loved or
keeping his confession to herself and I
knew that he would have probably served
the rest of his life in jail but that
family's peace to me was more important
than his freedom
that's when Brooke went to authorities
telling them she knew what happened to
Tara Grinstead and where her remains
could be found then she confronted beau
as that you need to confess you need to
own up to what you've done and confess I
said because that family deserves to
know what his bows say he says I just
want her family to know Ryan Duke was
arrested and charged with murder
beau Dukes who was not related was
charged with concealing her death and is
expected to be the star witness against
Ryan
so did he confess and is she still with
him that's what I was yeah well beau did
confess he told his deep dark secret and
that led to Ryan's arrest and yes they
are still together Brooke who was a
pharmacist very bright woman loves him
and is proud of him for coming forward
after all these years to help solve this
crime
thanks Mia great to see you thank you
thank you